hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear my little movie review
series
yes i finally got around to seeing this
movie i actually wanted to go see it in
the theater but by the time i sort of
got my lazy ass around to it it wasn't
playing anymore and then i was like well
i can watch it on streaming but then for
a while it was twenty dollars and i said
well i don't really wanna pay twenty
dollars to see it but finally finally on
the streaming service it was down to
like 5.99 and i was like okay that's
reasonable uh i'm finally gonna watch it
now so this is just 2022 movie x so as
most horror fans will know this was
directed by uh ty west this is newest
one now ty west started back in 2005 i
think was his first movie it was called
the roost which i think was like a
killer bat type movie i actually haven't
seen that
um but it wasn't actually until 2009
when that his sort of uh
satanic panic throwback uh sort of flick
house of the devil came out that
everybody kind of
said hey here's a guy we need to pay
attention to
um and then after that in 2011 he did
the innkeepers which is like a really
good like creepy paranormal type uh
horror and then in 2013 he released the
his kind of like found footage
reimagining of the jonestown massacre
which is called the sacrament it's
basically like a couple guys from vice
and they go to
a modern approximation of jonestown and
it's like a found footage which actually
is like pretty good um i actually didn't
mind it it got some mixed reviews but i
think i liked his other movies better
but it's actually like really good now
after that it seemed like he didn't
necessarily go away from horror but he
like branched out a little bit i guess
like he directed a western in 2016. i
can't remember the name of it right now
but and he did a lot of kind of um
tv episodes like he did wayward pines
and the passage and the resident likes
dramas sci-fi some horror in there as
well so then in spring of 2022 uh much
to horror fans delight he comes out with
this sort of grungy retro slasher flick
called x uh which was released through
a24 so again very excited about it and i
was very excited about it like i said
sorry it took me like so long to finally
get around to seeing i was just waiting
for the price to come down because like
i said if i go see it in the theater
then i don't have to pay because i have
amc stubs a-list so i get to see three
movies a week like for however much it
is like 20 bucks a month or something so
i was like well if i couldn't see it in
the theater and not have to pay then i
didn't want to pay 20 just to see one
movie so i had to wait for it to like
come down to a reasonable price so
that's why that's why i took them but i
did get around to watching it finally so
the movie x is set in 1979
and uh it's a very obviously an homage
to texas chainsaw massacre the original
1974 one you know the setup of it is
very similar and there's a lot of stuff
in it that you will recognize that it's
homaging like on purpose uh it's also
kind of
i don't want to say it's parodying but
it is kind of again lovingly homaging
sort of like the golden age of porn
which sort of started in the late 1960s
to late 1970s you know movies like deep
throat and the devil and miss jones and
things like that um you know so it's
kind of going for that uh kind of [ __ ]
as well
um so this movie i have to say this i
really enjoyed this movie a lot uh it's
a very very entertaining it's very
period accurate like to the late 1970s
very gory like the kills are really
gruesome which i really enjoyed and it
also has like some sly humor to it as
well which uh which i also really liked
so it's just kind of like you know just
basically a fun throwback to
late 70s early 80s porn and slashers
like kind of all mingled in there
together also um a little bit of an
oddly
sympathetic i guess i don't want to go
too far like saying sympathetic but the
villain is a little bit sympathetic in
the sort of psycho bitty subgenre as
they call it
which which is a term i only learned
like a few months ago and i'm like oh my
god that's fantastic but it basically
has to do with any horror movie where
like an old lady is like the villain
like a like a grotesque old lady so this
kind of has that uh going forward as
well so our main character is played by
mia goth um she was in she's been in
several things she was in a cure for
wellness uh she was in the 2018 suspiria
remake uh she's actually great in this
so
she's uh this aspiring porn star named
maxine mink
and she looks full on late 70s sex pop
man she's got like the feathered hair
she's got like all these freckles um she
has like this electric blue eye shadow
she's wearing these kind of like
overalls with nothing underneath them
it's just it's so [ __ ] 70s that it
hurts like the lip gloss and everything
it's like they really really got it like
spot on
so she's kind of a great but i'm you
know she looks great but she also has
like a lot of kind of like layers going
on even though this isn't really
explicitly stated outright
she seems to have a lot of insecurities
about her appearance and specifically
like i said they don't explicitly state
this but because she has so many
freckles and a lot of they put like a
lot of freckles on her like and there's
like they they're very very thick like
around her eye and everything like that
so i think she's
sort of like insecure about her
appearance and has gone maybe into porn
as sort of like self-validation i guess
because and she always like projects
this confidence like her this comfort
with her body which maybe she doesn't
entirely feel but she's like really good
at
sort of projecting that and she's kind
of one of those people that just thinks
i deserve the the very best and i'm not
gonna stop until i get it you know i'm
she's like very impatient she wants
everything like right now so she has an
older boyfriend uh who is also the porn
producer his name is wayne and he's
actually played by martin henderson who
i recognize from the ring he's been
unlike some other things as well
um so he tells uh maxine that she
basically has that x factor which again
it's kind of interesting how the title x
it almost kind of has like a triple
meaning because it's like it refers to
the x factor like she has it or whatever
the star quality is also because x
because it's like
about porn like about a porn movie and
also x i'm assuming because like x
chromosome like because it's a female
killer and it's kind of like about is i
don't know if it's i'd go so far as say
it's about female sexuality per se but
it does have that like as a big theme
so her boyfriend tells her you know
you've got the x factor this new movie
that we're working on is gonna make you
a star and it's gonna make all of us
really really rich um you know it's it's
gonna be this next big thing in porn and
they kind of because this is 1979 the
guy is like looking ahead to the
burgeoning uh you know home video market
which you know again was something that
actually was going on back at that time
so these two are accompanied by two more
kind of like veteran uh porn performers
uh bobby lynn who is played by brittany
snow who i recognized from would you
rather
and
the wonderfully named jackson hole
it was i was like that's his porn name
it's fantastic i was like jackson old
that's amazing uh he's actually played
by a rapper singer songwriter uh kid
cootie
and also they have like the guy who's
making the film like you know the the
cinematographer filmmaker whatever uh
his name is rj
and i was like oh i just saw that guy in
a movie it's uh owen campbell he was
just in my heart can't be unless you
tell it to like he played the vampire so
that's where i remembered him from
because i just saw that not too long ago
and he has a girlfriend who's also the
sound engineer for the film and her name
is lorraine she's played by jenna ortega
who was in uh the new scream movie like
the 2022 one she was in insidious
chapter two i think she started out on
uh jane the version that tv series so
yeah so these are kind of like all
pretty well-known people that you will
recognize so just like in texas chainsaw
massacre this whole gang have all piled
into their scooby van i guess if you
want to call it that and they're heading
out to this remote farm in texas now
this actually wasn't shot in texas this
was actually set in new zealand but
i didn't know that it wasn't texas i
mean it looks uh pretty good still now
they do just like in texas chainsaw
massacre they have like a little bit of
foreshadowing i guess like while they're
on their way there where like this cow
has gotten hit by a semi and it's like
pretty nasty and it's like just
splattered all over the road um you know
and the cops are kind of like you know
directing everyone around it so that's
kind of so you know like some bad shit's
gonna happen like down the down the way
so it turns out that they've rented this
cabin from an elderly couple and that's
where they're gonna shoot the porno
movie although obviously they haven't
told the old people this
uh the movie is actually called the
farmer's daughters because i guess they
couldn't think of more of like a less
cliched title but there you go
um i guess that's kind of like part of
the joke
so when they get there uh the old man
whose name is howard and he's actually
played by
uh steven ur and i he's like
unrecognizable this he was in deathgasm
i think he was in some episodes of ash
versus evil dead and stuff like that but
he's under like like old man prosthetics
so you probably won't recognize him so
he gets there and he's like oh well i
just thought it was gonna be one dude
like wayne and maybe his girlfriend i
didn't know all you [ __ ] were coming
and he's like oh well yeah i'll give you
extra money and he's like well i don't
really like the looks of you guys but he
takes their money anyway and he's
basically like yeah well just behave
yourselves and
don't upset my wife pearl um she's not
well and she gets confused and she kind
of like wanders around sometimes so just
kind of like leave her alone and stay
away from the house and [ __ ] like that
and you do actually see pearl like kind
of like creeping and like looking out
the window at them like watching them
arrive and [ __ ] like that uh
interestingly and i don't know
i guess for a little while it was kind
of like a secret but if you go on the
wikipedia page it's not but like pearl
is actually played by
miyagath also like the main girl in this
that plays maxine um again because i was
sitting there going man she looks
familiar i was like oh it's the same
chick but like it did even like it
didn't really like occur to me until
like afterward and i was like oh yeah i
guess that would be okay yeah so it was
the same so she plays like a dual role
but like i said she has so much
uh prosthetics like the old actually the
old people prosthetics in this are
actually really really good that you
probably would not recognize her i
didn't recognize that it was the same
actor and the fact that she plays both
roles is kind of like thematically
relevant as well
so for about the first half of the movie
we're just basically hanging out with
this group of people as they start
filming their porn extravaganza the
farmer's daughters
and you know they're just kind of like
sitting around drinking beers uh you
know having conversations about
appreciating your youth and you know
sexual liberation and stuff like that
like i said this is 1979 so they're kind
of going into that now lorraine who is
kind of like
very very
shy very retiring uh the others actually
call her church mouse
and she's uh she didn't know like coming
out here that this was gonna be a porn
film i guess her boyfriend didn't tell
her so at first she's kind of like
appalled and shocked and everything like
that watching like and she has to stand
there with the with the boom mic like
while they're you know going at it and
she's like
you know really kind of offended but
then like the more she watches it like
the more into it she gets uh so much so
that eventually she asks wayne the
producer if she can be in the movie
herself
um because she wants to like try it out
and like you know do this whole sexual
liberation thing and ironically her
boyfriend rj
is absolutely not having this and this
tries to come up with all these excuses
why she can't do it even though
ironically he had like teased her for
being a prude when
you know before they got there and when
she found out that it was a porn shoot
and she was like all offended by it and
he's like oh you're such a prude and
stuff but obviously when she wants to be
in the movie oh no no you know what i
mean the kid did i was like yeah that's
pretty typical
now meanwhile uh the spooky old lady
pearl is kind of like skulking around
now they're the cabin they're staying in
is like on the
old people's property but it's kind of
like a a distance away you know what i
mean it's kind of like across this big
field
so she's kind of like wandering around
like looking in the windows like
watching them like while they're
shooting the movie like watching the
people having sex and stuff like that
and you can tell she's kind of
that she's kind of into it but like in a
kind of resentful way there's also like
a really creepy scene where
maxine
kind of goes to the house like looking
around like to ask somebody something
and she has this really really weird
like interaction with pearl where
they're like sitting across the table
and they're having lemonade and
and they're not really talking and pearl
is just kind of like looking at her
really creepily and then she like says
all this stuff to her like maxine is
like looking at pictures of pearl when
she was like younger and she's like see
i was beautiful once and
and all this others then she just starts
to like kind of touch her like creepily
like on her side boob and stuff and
she's like what the [ __ ] this is like
really weird so it's that kind of stuff
so yeah so it turns out that
what pearl's deal is is that old howard
her husband
uh can't really give her what she needs
anymore sexually because he has a bad
heart and he is so he's like afraid
he'll kill over
so pearl has been increasingly like
getting increasingly resentful
of
being constantly reminded that she can't
sexually get what she needs anymore that
she's not young and beautiful anymore
you know that now she's this very very
old woman
and so she is getting like really
resentful at seeing like all these
beautiful young people like just kind of
swanning around the property um you know
being all young and hot and humping each
other and without a care in the world
and [ __ ] like that
so it gets to a point where pearl's
frustration
eventually builds up to a point where
she just starts like offing them one by
one so like you know it's a slasher
movie so ever
pretty much everybody's gonna get killed
and i have to say the kills in this are
actually pretty great they're pretty uh
disgusting very gory and it mostly looks
like uh practical effects which is
fantastic
uh implication also being that she's
done this before you don't really know
how many times
but at least once and maybe more than
that um and the thing about it is that
howard
while not directly
participating in the killing for sure
knows what she's doing and helps her
cover [ __ ] up and helps her out like in
her so he's kind of her accomplice i
guess so as i mentioned x is a classic
slasher like in its own right
but it does a couple like takes a couple
different like spins with some of the
tropes uh one of the main tropes that it
sort of up ends is the virginal one the
virginal one as final girl um like it
kind of upends that some and i feel like
uh for a slasher it's generally pretty
sex-positive
uh because you know your classic
slashers were usually you know the more
promise promiscuous you were like the
more punished you got and i'm not saying
that that doesn't happen here because
like i said pretty much everybody gets
killed but
it's not necessarily like the most
versional one that survives and it's not
necessarily like pearl's motivations
while sexual are not really in the way
that they're like she's not so much
punishing them for having sex she's
punished well i guess she is but she's
punishing them for having sex because
she can't have it you know what i mean
so it's kind of more like that more than
a sort of
reactionary type of theme i guess so it
does like a couple different like uh
kind of things with it
uh the thing about pearl too is that she
seems to have
almost like a sexual attraction toward
maxine herself
um you know there's one point where she
like you know turns up in her bed and
she's like you know caressing her and
stuff like that i i don't know if it's
so much like she wants to
[ __ ] her or if she just wants to be her
you know what i mean because there's a
lot of stuff about
pearl
you know
lamenting her lost youth how she used to
be she used to be this beautiful young
dancer and it's like howard would do
anything for her all she had to do was
you know be beautiful and like bat her
eyelashes and men would be like wrapped
around her little finger and the fact
that she can't have that anymore is like
really really getting to her uh so she
is lamenting that and also like what the
very long long years that she's lived
have like done to her face and her body
uh because obviously she looks like a
very very old woman now um so yeah
there's some kind of weird like you know
real creepy this is not creepy but it's
it's meant to like show her as grotesque
but also like sympathetic and she is
sympathetic it doesn't excuse what she
does obviously because she just like
kills a bunch of innocent people but
you understand where she's coming from
she's a villain but you understand like
where she's coming from and in some of
the scenes particularly where she's
talking to howard um you do kind of like
feel sorry for her and for him as well
like a little bit even though like i
said it absolutely doesn't excuse what
they do because they do some pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ] so uh so yeah the whole
look and feel of this movie is um a real
highlight i really do like these movies
and it's tai west in particular who
really tries to make movies that look
very much like something that could have
come out in 1979 and this absolutely
does look like that just the way it's
shot it really does look and feel like a
1979 movie um they also use kind of a
lot of a lot of period appropriate like
am radio kind of uh music and [ __ ] like
that which really kind of puts you in
that whole vibe that whole head space
because i was alive back then so i kind
of remember what it was like um i mean i
was only like seven or eight but still
and the characters are all like
interesting and they're largely likable
there's like they're a little bit
douchey but not really like not in a way
that you want to see them get killed so
it actually is just entertaining just
kind of like hanging out with them too
like for the first half of the movie or
whatever before people start getting
killed um but then again it's also
entertaining but also a little bit of a
bummer like when they start getting
killed because you're just like oh
because you kind of liked them you know
what i mean um i don't know i just
thought that was good the characters
were all really good and like really
distinct from one another it wasn't it
wasn't a kind of thing where
they were all kind of like samey like
they all had they didn't go huge into
their backstories but they all had like
enough of a distinct personality that
they all seemed like separate people
without being see me so i thought that
was really good too but again like the
gore in this is pretty great people get
bludgeoned they get stabbed they get eye
gouged there's a scene in there that was
reminded me very much of uh you know a
lucio folgi style uh eye gouging so
points there uh you know somebody gets
blasted with a shotgun uh people get run
over with cars like their heads get run
over with cars and it's just it's pretty
glorious like it's really really
gruesome and i really dug it
so i mean if you're into 70s or 80s
slashers and want to see something like
a more modern take on one that still
kind of still has that vintage vibe like
retains that vintage vibe a little bit
then x is like really absolutely worth
seeing it's really fun it's really
gruesome uh has lots of nudity lots of
sex lots of great kills in it and has a
killer that has a little bit of a
different thing going on um you know
something you don't see like in a lot of
slasher movies
and i will say that i think of all of
the horror movies of all of thai west
horror movies that i've seen which is
all of them except for the roost uh this
one's easily my favorite like i said i
really did like his other ones but this
one's really really good and i liked
this one a lot it was just a lot of fun
so that will do it for this flickers of
fear let me know what you thought about
x in the comments and i will see you
again on the next one bye